c'est une europe qui permet d'affronter
toutes les circonstances de la vie je
crois que je suis content tout les
ségrégations qu'elle soit la ségrégation
de la couleur qu'elle sur la ségrégation
du sexe je ne dis pas qu'il faut saviez
comme ça je dis on peut s'habiller comme
ça c'est ma révolution est ce que vous
en pensez qui c'est ridicule
pourquoi presque jamais volé bas à
seulement pas je suis un peu vieux mais
enfin si j'étais plus jeune louis
que c'est affreux moi j'aurais pas
m'habiller comme ça pas du tout ce dont
vous aurez un mari est ce que vous
aimeriez qu'ils soient affiliés comme ça
ce n'est tous les départs hey pourquoi
pas marquer que ça s'est déjà fait les
robes pour fin pour romain de toute
façon c'est pas ce n'est qu'un
recommencement la mode n'est qu'un
éternel recommencement révèle le
couturier cet amant les gares deviennent
de plus en plus féminin c'est plus des
mecs fallait se trimballer en jupe comme
ça vous trouvez pas ça ridicule que je
trouve ridicules c'est que ce soit
ridicule